[Music]
foreign
michal thank you for joining us and
thank you for bringing mika along
my pleasure say hi she knows how to say
bye
oh wow she's so beautiful
thank you michal
so thank you for joining us while you're
on maternity leave and
during coronavirus times and
so you um you ran and are running one of
the most
incredible things that i got to see in
terms of community
and innovation especially in the startup
nation
what is campus tel aviv and
take me back to the beginning and walk
me through what the hell happened there
oh wow um very interesting i think it
was almost eight years ago
80 years wow there were a few few
amazing people from um company of google
that had an amazing idea of creating
a space that is dedicated for
entrepreneurs
for people that want to start a venture
or already have a venture
and um they need some help and supports
and back in the days eight years ago
here in tel aviv um there
it was like only a few organizations
that dealt with um
with entrepreneurship and startups which
is crazy to think because today there's
dozens
right unbelievable elevators incubators
you name it but back in the days there
was
only a few only a couple um
so i came along and joined the company
and um
as part of my like 20 of dedicating
extra time out of my position um
i basically fell in love with this idea
um
and wanted to join and create this thing
with those people
those amazing amazing people so you'll
see mathias of course
and amir shabbat and
and myself started thinking about this
space
um we had a floor
and they basically told us do whatever
you want
we took old furniture from the old
office that we just
moved away from and and basically
built something we were very hopeful we
didn't have a lot of idea what it will
be
we had some sort of a structure what was
the
so so what was the mission sort of when
they said here's a floor
what what is like your overarching goal
that you're trying to achieve with this
program that you're
eventually calling campus tel aviv
so basically what we wanted to do we
wanted to say hey
we're google we have a lot of experience
as entrepreneurs
we ourselves started as a startup and we
thought that we have a lot to share with
this ecosystem of startups
and and to bring them more and also to
take all the tools
and and human resources that google has
in order to to help entrepreneurs do you
agree with that
um so that basically was the mission you
know to help
yeah to create communities that
will be actually supported guided
and and be from the community
so so okay so now we have a so we have
an office and you put some furniture
and you say okay now what
okay so now we have now we have a floor
what do you do now so it was it was
super interesting because
you know a lot of reporters came and the
prime minister of israel back in the
days came
yeah and he cut a digital ribbon which
was super cool
eight years ago um and then we said
we're opening our doors and like a
whole lot of people came really yeah
a lot of people came we knew that we
have
space a space that we're giving to
people to host their events
yeah we had program called launch pad
right that is a
plan for new startups to help them um
get on their
feet and get support but basically we
didn't know
anything out of that um so
i what i did is
i tried to speak with every person
that got in our doors and asked them who
are you
where are you coming from what do you do
what do you think campus is
what do you want you know try to ask
them a lot of questions
in order to understand how people see
us and what we should be um
it was like hundreds of conversation in
the first month
so which almost seemed which almost
seems minuscule compared to the hundreds
of thousands of
people that were flocking in over time
right
holy but i think that like
any other place in the world and any
other job profession
you need to get down to the ground and
speak with you yeah
because the first lesson that i learned
is that what we tried to portray to by
campus and we said
numerous time that we're not a working
space
everybody thought that we're a working
space i came to work there yeah
exactly so we realized that we're
portraying a message that nobody got and
we need to change things and we need to
understand
um where's the jam of what we do what is
the best thing that we do
and what we need to to change and i
think that back in the days
creating the event space and giving
people the
opportunity to host a free event and
also to give them like flight snacks and
to give them
a prank that is distinguished to hold
their tech events was
was the best thing that we could do
because in that sense we created
a huge community that is called campus
but
many communities of different aspects
industries verticals groups of people
that got together in campus
that we provided a home for them so i
mean just
to get the idea anybody i mean looking
eight years ago anybody could just go
online to the website
and basically say i want to host an
event i want
either a large space or a small space
and then they just
show up with their 100 guests and their
snacks and drinks ready for them
there's tech support to connect
everything and it's all for free
yep that's very unusual
yes it was very unusual back in the days
it's still unusual today
i i visited a hackathon in campus tel
aviv i think
right around the time that it was just
starting out it was about seven eight
years ago you know you had a hundred and
about a hundred teenagers running around
and
who would have thought that there would
be a space that somebody could just
organize a hackathon for free
as somebody who organized hackathons it
costs a lot of money usually
yeah and i think that's the first you
know
step in creating a community yes
communities online are great
but if you want to make them
long-lasting you need
some physical aspect which is kind of
strange nowadays
in corona times that we have to figure
out how to create
something that just stays online without
any human connection
[Music]
but the space provided something that's
lived outside of the screen outside of
the internet
so people can converse people can can
beat can create things together
and i think that thanks to all those
hackathons that happened in campus
people meeting
a lot of new companies got together
relationships yeah their food you know
all those kind of things
happy nice things um and you need you
need a space to do that
and if you wanted to host an event back
in the day
uh you needed to pay a lot of good money
yeah
an understanding on how to host an event
because
most of the event hosts were people that
did it voluntarily
you know out of their work yeah on the
free time
they just wanted to share something and
they wanted to do good
and they had no clue how to host an
event
and we could give them also extra
information
[Music]
on how to market it how to get to the
right crowd
which is yeah important things to do and
we also provide that
no no completely anyway
yeah so let's leave in corona
so let's fast forward what are some do
do you have handy some of the statistics
how many
over these past eight years what
happened in campus about how many people
came how many events
i i lost count at some time
but it was it was something like around
1 000 events per year
oh my god a thousand events a year
that's an average of three events a day
yes i don't think i don't know of any
space that that does that
it just shows that if you give an
opportunity to people they take it with
both hands
yeah okay so now we fast forward and
last year
i had the privilege of being at the
launch party at
a building called google for startups
so what is this what is this transition
and what is this building
so i can speak um not fully about this
because
i was on maternity leave and i'm also
now a little bit focused on different
subjects
yeah and now there is an amazing
unbelievable team that is running campus
television
um with uh which you know who's managing
this
amazingly uh but what we said is that
there's so much that is going on we wish
we had more space
so we can give to more people and we can
do more
um so a lot of new things came
um
yeah no i mean and just that you know
the transition from going from a floor
to a building
in the heart of tel aviv in one of the
most
you know wanted areas right next to the
train station i mean it really just
shows that
it's it's about the value that is that
it's being given
and and i have a lot of friends who are
who are constantly there
both as sitting at their desk working
there but also just going to events
so i'd love to pick your brain about
community
so how many years were you involved with
campus tel aviv
project um seven years so over these
seven years
you you must have become some sort of an
expert on community management and both
things that worked and things that
didn't work
and i'd love to hear both sides because
it seems that
so many people are trying to start
communities and i tried starting
communities in the past
and it's sort of this like this unknown
question mark of what does it mean a
community what does it mean to be
engaged how do you get people engaged
what is a community for you i think
you know i i've asked my question
this question many times yeah i had a
master's degree in communication and i i
decided to
uh research this topic of communities
and something that i realized is that
the rise
of this position of community management
was actually
um in the same time of a decrease
in um in the position of tech
evangelists yep
so nowadays there's no need
to explain to people about technology
right
there's a need to explain about a
product about a company
so it means different things
so i thought
that maybe it could be it could be a
little bit
easier if i can look at a community like
a product
okay that what is
what is it needs to say what is it
selling yeah
who are people who are the customers and
really look at it
in a very you know business yeah
kind of witness because i feel that
even today this world community takes
you
to more social good
and a place right right
nonprofit right but most of the
communities that we're talking about
today
are communities that are actually for
business
and it's a different kind of thing
because
if it's a non-profit if it's uh for good
for doing good
people have a very strong connection
that they want to stay connected online
[Music]
purpose you have to be super focused to
understand what you're selling
and why the hell people will go online
and do
something that relates to it right right
and that's a very tough lesson that i
learned
back in the days in campus wait a
[Music]
yeah second interesting timing of course
so i think that once i realized that
is that i'm trying to sell something
even if it's not
something that people pay for it right
yeah it took me to a different kind of
place and to
something that i i thought created a
better service for
cannabis right just understanding for
those people that we wanna
sell yeah was it was it beneficial to
actively measure your engagement and
and whether you had good weeks bad weeks
or was that less relevant
throughout the process i think that we
struggle
a lot with measurement because we don't
know what
measure and how to measure yeah you have
like
the you know the numbers
that everybody can see like uh
in facebook how many people are online
engagement but it wasn't enough for
us so what we try to do is we try to
created in the real world offline i
think i lost you in that last sentence
can you repeat that one more time
yeah do you hear me right now yep
so what we try to do is because you know
campus
is a space it's a physical space yeah
and what we're trying to do is to bring
people to our space
or to create something that is physical
is
how much of what we've done online
actually happened on offline
uh okay so for instance if we wanted to
host an event and we posted it online
how many people came so we started you
know giving questionnaires at the end of
each event
sure and asked well where how did you
hear about our event
yeah with facebook um
so that gave us some sort of an
information
um also for a while we try to give
like specific discounts for services for
entrepreneurs for people that
saw it online
in our online communities and again
once we realize that it's a product
we're selling a space
we want things to happen in space it has
no
you know it doesn't mean anything if
you've done something that only stays
online
no it it makes perfect perfect sense and
she's she's just so cute and and
honestly you know i've been
i've been at campus say dozens dozens of
times
uh both you know you you hosted you
helped me host some hackathons there
and and and different projects and i got
to visit so many events
and i i feel like i really learned a lot
about what it means to
to run communities through campus and
it's not only about
the the community of campus but it's
also about how
how do you help people run communities
you know i believe she codes
one of their first locations was in
campus and you have all these different
organizations that
really really it just accelerated their
engagement because all of a sudden you
have this place that everybody knows
already
you when you host an event and and you
say yeah we're meeting in campus tel
aviv
yeah of course we're all yeah campus tel
aviv we know how to get there we know
what it is
the friction is reduced dramatically and
and
the value that people i mean i just
remember you walking in you just get
such a good vibe
so really thank you for thank you for
doing it i mean it's a
pleasure i i mean i grew up with it and
it's and it really
it really transformed it really helped
me transform into
into an entrepreneur that's trying to
learn and and be curious
and mikhail before you have to go back
uh to
to managing this corona time and corona
and sorry for the seasick because i'm
jumping
i need three words that describe
uh you mother okay
um creative
[Music]
um
so mother creative arts yeah
i love it michal thank you so much
it was a pleasure a pleasure thank you
and stay healthy